what's up fellow geeks zacky here from
geek culture bringing you another
fantastic unboxing video and you guessed
it right it's iphone season baby and
what we have here is the iphone 13 mini
the iphone 13 the iphone 13 pro and the
iphone 13
pro max
alongside we have the iphone 12 the
iphone 12 pro and the iphone 12 pro max
now i'm not gonna run through the specs
because you've probably already seen
that in other videos on youtube and of
course the apple event itself now what i
am going to talk about is how it looks
how it feels and compare them to the
iphone 12s now if you guys would like to
skip ahead we are going to add
timestamps in the description below so
do skip ahead if you need to alright
guys this is the moment we've been
waiting for let's open up the iphone 13
pro max
in sierra blue
look at that
wow
check this out beautiful
i can see why people want the sierra
blue so let's take a quick minute and
compare it with the iphone 12 pro max
now in terms of size
very similar
but you can probably tell that the
iphone 13 pro max
has larger cameras
than the iphone 12 pro max and looking
at the front of the phone the placement
of the speaker here is much higher
towards the edge
of the bezels right there it's much
wider as well compared to the iphone 12
but the camera placement on the iphone
13
is on
my right side while the iphone 12 is on
the left
so minute differences here
but we can expect the same out of the
rest of the iphone 13s as well now as
you can tell the edges of the screen
still very similar
the only differences here is that the
iphone 13 pro max has 120 hertz screen
oh man that is smooth
this video is brought to you by
circles live our preferred mobile
carrier what we love about circles live
is having the flexibility and freedom to
create your own bespoke mobile plan be
it more data or more talk time and the
ability to check your bill and balance
on the fly with that easy to use mobile
app the best part about being a circus
life member is that there are subscriber
rewards all year round participate in
activities and community challenges and
be rewarded with bonus data
and even free ice cream but wait there's
more if you use this code get thirty
dollar wave of your bill and unlimited
data for three months
that's a lot of data with that out of
the way it's time to go back to the
video
let's go with the iphone 13 pro
in gold
very similar fashion to the sierra blue
but of course in
gold even the bezels has a gold tint
comparing the size of the pro max to the
pro
that's a little bit shorter
now comparing it to the iphone 12 can
you see the difference
fray unkenny
you would have not known
camera's still bigger
there you go you spot it
now the pro edition of the iphone 13s
are different in terms of display
they are 120 hertz
blazing fast very smooth and we can
expect games to run 120 120hz
on a higher frame rate settings
so
yeah
let's move on to the iphone
13
standard
okay for for this video set we're going
to call it extended
and it's
and it comes in my favorite color
which is pink
and there's nothing emasculating about
pink
i think it's a great color
and just to compare how it actually
looks like in the packaging
and how it looks like on the phone it's
going to come off a little bit more
whitish
but in our eyes it's actually a pretty
nice pastel pink
now comparing it you will understand why
there is a
standard version and a pro version the
pro version being that it has three
camera modules at the back of the phone
and the regular iphone 13 has two camera
modules
now the third camera module is basically
a telephoto lens comparing it to
the iphone 12 you can see that the
placement of the cameras are different
as well
on the iphone 13 it's more diagonal
and on the iphone 12 it's
on a vertical position
last but not least
let's move on to the iphone 13
mini this is the most exciting one
for
me because it's nice and petite
it's very cute
look at this like it fits my whole pile
man
it's nice it
reminds me of
the old iphones when they weren't going
so big
and this
will be very handy
and it's so responsive right now
four variants of the iphone 13 here
but take a look at that guys
man i really wish we had the green the
greenwood stand out so much
apple you know what's up
get us green
gotta show the people we need green
so final thoughts which of these iphones
from the iphone 13 lineup is for you
well let's look at three different
factors here starting with the 120 hertz
refresh rate now these can only be found
in the pro models of the iphone 13 which
is the iphone 13 pro and iphone 13 pro
max this is a great feature because a
lot of the iphone users
really wish they had 120 hertz display
and this 120 hertz display puts it on
par with other flagship smartphones
second of all is the new cinematic mode
which is available across all the models
look it doesn't matter whether you're a
video professional
whether you're a content creator or just
want to record precious moments with
your family this new cinematic mode
makes it easier to create highly
stylized and more polished look on your
videos
it's like having hollywood in your
pocket man last but not least is the
apple prores lossy video compression for
the 13 pro models that includes the
iphone 13 pro max and the iphone 13 pro
a little disclaimer here is that the 128
gigabyte storage option only gives you
apple prores at 1080p
at 30 frames per second meanwhile if
you're gonna get a 256 gigabyte model
and up then you're gonna get apple pro s
at 4k 30 frames per second so that's one
thing to take note of when you're
getting any of these pro models what
apple has done here
is as the saying goes if it ain't broke
don't fix it now it does share certain
similarities with the iphone 12 lineup
but that isn't a bad thing at all it's
more of the inner beauty of these phones
such as its upgraded hardware and its
upgraded camera systems so if you have
any questions about any of these iphone
13s do let us know in the comments down
below so there you have it guys thank
you so much for watching this video and
if you enjoyed it do give us a thumbs up
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
it helps us a lot follow us on our
social media pages right here and until
then this is zacky signing off
whoa
[Music]